[Musique]
donnez vie à nanou croyait avoir
rencontré l'amour est pas moins réelle
tout a bien commencé et puis ensuite il
a commencé à être très jaloux où es tu
ou votre sujet et beaucoup de questions
sur les personnes que je voyais mais
c'était déjà trop
je suis dit que j'allais quitter ça ne
lui a pas plu et il m'a dit où tu seras
avec moi où tu seras personnes
c'est la famille au banana et c'était il
ya cinq ans après la rupture il ya eu
les menaces les insultes la peur puis un
bras cassé
aujourd'hui un âne ne sort jamais de la
maison sans avoir à la main ce téléphone
portable pour elle c'est une véritable
bouée de sauvetage en appareils bien
spéciale qui la relie en tout temps à la
police pressé c'est selon moi oui on
peut alors que je vois ce cellulaire
ça ressemble à un cellulaire normal tu
vois dans les rues aux noms je suis en
train d'appeler c'est en train de sonner
bonjour non non tout va bien je me suis
trompé j'ai appelé sans le vouloir
excuser moi perdre un ami nous pour les
céréales
ça ne peut pas être plus vrai c'est
comme ça que ça se passe
et vous avez vu que l'appel est très
rapide elle m'a répondu en une minute
autre piste à quang est là et c'est
quelqu'un doit te parler et si tu ne
réponds pas ils savent que tu es en
danger et ils savent où je suis
[Musique]
cet appareil elle le doit à une loi
adoptée en 2004 par le parlement
espagnol
la loi de protection intégrale contre
les violences de genre a mis en place
des mesures comme la création de
tribunaux spécialisés et d'un système de
suivi et de protection des victimes
à chaque victime
on assigne aux policiers spécialisés qui
sera toujours le même
ce sera son policier protecteur grâce au
programme informatique biogen les
policiers détermine le niveau de risque
auquel fait face une victime et propose
des mesures spécifiques de protection et
de soutien psychologique dans une
protection contre un risque extrême la
protection policière et 24 heures sur 24
c'est une escorte policière qui va
accompagner la femme dans tous ses
mouvements
chacun des policiers de cette station
est responsable d'une centaine de cas
dont ils connaissent chaque détail une
centaine de femmes dont la protection
devient une affaire personnelle et
spontanée où l'ia a longtemps caché à
son entourage sa détresse psychologique
les bleus et les blessures qui
recouvrait son corps mille fois meurtri
par son ex mari
c'est une amie qui lui a finalement
forcé la main pour se rendre à la police
williams et byron bay et je me suis mise
à pleurer j'ai commencé à tous leur
raconter ils m'ont dit que je devais
porter plainte
je n'osais pas du lot mais a très bien
non la trêve et je leur ai dit que non
je ne vais plus chez lui je ne le
laisserai plus jamais le frapper ou
sinon j'irai dénonce ixina vaut lui à
ferrals radio choqués les vérifier mais
les policiers ont refusé m'ont dit
qu'ils devaient agir d'office ils sont
partis ils ont mis en détention et
ensuite ils ont mis en place le
dispositif de sécurité
on peut pêcher dans la dèche projets
terroristes
c'est une des particularités de la loi
espagnole policiers médecins aux voisins
peuvent porter plainte au nom d'une
victime qui souvent refusent de le faire
rapidement le tribunal doit se saisir du
cas en moins de 72 heures selon la loi
le divorce de rougnat a été prononcée
sur le champ par une juge
on lui a remis un téléphone d'urgence et
il est soutenu par la garde civile et
par des psychologues en attendant le
prononcé d'une sentence définitive de
son agresseur elle pourrait aller de la
prison au port d'un bracelet anti
rapprochement pour son ex mari la tâche
est quoi tu te rends compte qu'il ya des
gens pour toi que les forces de sécurité
de l'état sont avec toi qu il t'aide
lâche rural assure najat race le modèle
espagnol a fait ses preuves en 2003
l'espagne dénombré 71 p mini-site contre
54 l'année dernière un chiffre qui
stagne depuis plusieurs années la
politique solano poser le problème de la
violence faite aux femmes va au delà de
la violence en tant que tel arias est
nécessaire d' éduquer et sensibiliser
les garçons et de filles pour que demain
il n'y ait pas de violences dans leur
couple
il insista est à berlin sia le cafrad
capitaux il manque beaucoup ici c'est
l'éducation contre le machisme
je me dis que mon fils ne deviendra pas
comme lui
qu'il tient les femmes en haute estime
il sait que les femmes il faut les aimer
et protéger